in other news actor Kevin Spacey says
allegations that he sexually assaulted
in Massachusetts teenager are patently
false
the former house of cards star pleaded
not guilty yesterday to a single count
of indecent assault and battery he faces
up to five years in prison if convicted
Jericka Duncan was in the courtroom for
Spacey's arraignment on Nantucket
Jericka good morning good morning the 59
year olds attorneys have begun to
outline their defense in new court
filings it appears that they described
this interaction as mutual and
consensual flirtation it also appears
that not only do they plan to attack the
credibility of that alleged victim but
also his mother indecent assault and
battery on person 14 or over a silent
Kevin Spacey whose legal name is Kevin
Fowler stood before a judge yesterday to
face criminal charges for sexual assault
after Spacey's lawyers entered a not
guilty plea the judge ordered the
two-time Oscar winner to leave his
accuser alone Yolo you were required to
stay away and have no contact direct or
indirect with up with the alleged victim
alright the assault allegedly took place
in a crowded Nantucket bar called the
club car in July of 2016 the then 18
year old busboy told police Spacey
repeatedly groped him for about three
minutes investigators say the accuser
not only captured part of the assault
and a brief snapchat video he also
texted his girlfriend about it Tracy's
lawyers argued Monday those messages may
prove the encounter was consensual this
is data that we believe is not only
potentially exculpatory but likely
exculpatory for mr. Spacey in court
filings they said the alleged victim
misled Spacey by claiming he was a 23
year old college student and that he
joked about the incident with friends
for months former Boston news anchor
Heather Unruh is the accusers mother he
did not report the crime at the time and
that was largely because of
embarrassment and fear
multiple men have a queue space sea of
sexual assault
spacy previously denied some of those
claims but they still might be used
against him in this criminal case that
CBS News legal analyst Ricky Clayman any
prosecutor would try to locate other
accusers who have similar incidents with
Kevin Spacey what you need are witnesses
who will say that what happened to them
was so similar that it was a pattern the
alleged victims attorney says that his
client decided to report the sexual
assault because he wanted to encourage
other potential victims to come forward
now ironically enough hours after
Spacey's court appearance he was pulled
over in the DC area for speeding the
officer let him go with just a warning
Nora
all right Eureka thank you so much